a Democrat has been held accountable for
his crimes sort of at least a little bit
Democrat Congressman Jamal Bowman who
last March called me a Nazi hellbent on
keeping only white men alive and in
power has been indicted for falsely
pulling a fire alarm at the US capital
He was ordered to report to Capital
Police Headquarters yesterday to be
booked fingerprinted photographed and
processed and the charge carries a
maximum penalty of 6 months in jail
which Bowman will never serve because
actually here's the best part he's
pleading guilty and therefore he's just
paying a fine and apologizing while it
might be fun to send him to jail I'm
actually more satisfied by the guilty
plea because the guilty plea proves that
Congressman Bowman who initially denied
the crime is in fact a Shameless liar
did I mention he called me a Nazi back
in March